[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
harel tu préfères avis plus et de la
gueule ou avis avoir une crotte de nez
qui pensent comme toi là quand ça se met
tout le temps servir tu parles même si
de fait pousser une moustache à la
creuse de naître à paris je suis l'amour
flash comme ça si tu pue de la gueule
ouverte à une crotte de nez comme ça qui
compte tu veux la vie un peu les autres
boîtes de nuit quand même pu y ait de la
gueule chambre où tu peux le décrire les
avancées de la gueule mais pas faire ce
que vous voulez purée de pois non mais
la crotte de nez s'il vous plaît ce moi
je prends la crotte de nez ou non parce
que je m'appelle fans ou d'asie la
gueule très bien ah oui tu préfère
parler une langue que seul toit comprend
ou pas les français mais finir toutes
tes phrases par nico boucle du genre
mais pas même quand est calme tu vas
chez le conflit où en sont mécontents
nique au bout et voilà partout quoi
risque quand même de plus de récupérer
de losail en finissant par nico ou comme
faisant pas comprendre sur ma carrière
donc ni que j'attends l'album un gars
passionné ne retiens pas tes larmes
nico tu préfères avis avoir les cheveux
qui sentent la chekhchoukha la tunisie
doivent y avoir un cheveu au milieu du
crâne tialata qu'un cheveu à saluer mon
neveu non non je peux pas je préfère que
ça fouette on va voir ça fouette op tu
préfères avis avoir une tête de pélicans
et qu'on soit là du csa ou avis avoir un
qu à la place du menton maintenant des
faits cela se voir juste un pélican pour
que je me fasse chercher pénitents son
malheur la normale et correspond à près
à celle là je veux d'abord voir le fait
que bien alors on karine etter avoir
avis une cacahuète coincé dans la narine
mois que j'ai peur de la suite
noisy commenté m tu commences et essai
n'est ce pas aulas papier mais qui passe
à algajola papier mais qui passa oui on
embrasse aliana cameroun bien entendu
enfin tu préfère manger une ré over
avec georges pernoud thalassa est à
lhassa où un grec tso samedi bal avec
nikos aliagas grecque un giro était
resté pote avec nikos papote ses
meilleurs ensembles travaille ensemble
on s'apprécie si surtout c'est quelqu'un
quand on connaît que très humain
j'aimerais bienveillant avec lio tu peux
avoir des discussions de ouf sur ta vie
sur la vie en général il est très très
très très intelligente cultivée et j'en
passe mais je sais que ce que tu
préfères chez les grecs
c'est un cos c'est